joe biden is the first u.s president to
take part in commemorations for what's
thought to be the us's
worst incident of racial violence some
300 black residents of the once
prosperous
african-american neighborhood of
greenwood and tulsa were killed in 1921
as it was burned to the ground biden met
with the last survivors of the massacre
and pledged to address the systemic
racism that keeps african-americans
disadvantaged
promising to address inequity in home
appraisals black homes being valued at
tens of thousands less than white homes
and order more federal contracts for
black businesses the data shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
local businesses welcome the focus but
the head of the greenwood chamber of
commerce that was formed by survivors of
the massacre as they attempted to
rebuild
is skeptical the president of the united
states is here
and i can't even meet him to talk about
how we can preserve this district
how we can help grow these black
businesses the city of tulsa is making
money
the state of oklahoma is making money
right these
mainstream hotels is making money but
the historic black
district is not going to get a dime
biden hasn't advanced a key campaign
pledge to forgive student debt which
civil rights groups say would go a long
way to narrowing that racial wealth gap
nor has he
spoken out in favor of reparations for
slavery or even reparations for the
remaining
survivors of the tulsa race massacre who
a hundred years
after they lost everything still have
received no compensation
there hasn't been any accountability for
the massacre either white mobs were
actively supported by the police and
city authorities
activists see a direct link between
today's disproportionate police violence
against african americans
and the burning of what was known as
black wall street my brother terrence
crutcher was killed
right here in this community with his
hands in the air unarmed
by a police officer of tulsa oklahoma
and 100 years prior to that my
great-grandmother her community
this sacred land i'm standing on was
burnt to the ground state sanctioned
violence it's the same police culture
that
exists today that continues to harm
black and brown people
in this city from racial economic
disparities to official racist violence
this commemoration has revealed deep
continuity between nineteen twenty one
and twenty twenty one shia britancy al
jazeera tulsa oklahoma
dominic whitehead is vice president of
campaigns of the national association
for the advancement of colored people
also known as the naacp he says
counseling student debt would go a long
way to closing the wealth gap something
emitted from biden's speech
i think now we're in a place um we've
been in this place particularly african
americans
um in this country we begin to discuss
uh
issues around racial equity um
and closing the wealthy gap in this
country the
administration is definitely going in
the right direction when we
think about uh fair housing and really
looking at
the housing we think about education and
investing into hbcus
but also in urban and rural education
we're looking at the job market and
looking at the infrastructure bill
that's still in congress right now we
know that is going into the right
direction
however we also know that african
americans are disproportionately
affected by student loan debt like many
americans
um so being able to cancel student debt
um will automatically and almost
immediately
change um some of the wealth gaps that
we see in this country when you think
about
um being able to purchase a home um
right home
ownership is is typically the the fast
track in terms of
gaining some type of wealth and
beginning to close the wealth gap in so
many right on so many ways
um so we know the numbers are there the
data is there um
that you know the cancellation of
student debt particularly for african
americans
will be a step in the right direction
now again everything that the president
lifted up
on today what came out of the budget
last towards the end of last week before
the memorial day holiday
it's definitely a step in the right
direction but we need to go further and
we can go further and that conversation
is absolutely around
the student debt